hey 42 here the Milky Way the swirling
mass of galaxies that we call home is
100,000 light-years in diameter even if
we could travel at the speed of light it
would still take 100,000 years to travel
from one side of this great unknown to
the other but what if I told you there
is a way you could explore almost the
entire Milky Way within your lifetime
without having to worry about achieving
light speed there's just one small
caveat you must be able to maintain a
constant 1g acceleration that's the same
force as Earth's gravitational pull
if however your hypothetical spaceship
could maintain such a near-impossible
level of unrelenting acceleration then
you could due to the effects of time
dilation travel to the center of the
Milky Way and back again in just 40
years but when you return to Earth it
would be sixty thousand years in the
future also if you could maintain that
elusive 1g acceleration you could reach
the edge of the observable universe in a
single human lifetime what you would
actually do when you get there remains
to be discovered
picture this it is the longest hour of
your life and also the heaviest in all
the four hours and 35 minutes a thousand
lifetimes would pass by on earth
generations would be born and inevitably
face
yet to you all of a single afternoon
would have passed you by
this would be your experience if you
spend just one day on an imaginary
planet in the ghostliness of space a
thousand light years from Earth
let's call this imaginary planet Zed our
42a which is just a modicum catchier
than GQ loopy be currently the largest
exoplanets we have discovered estimated
to be up to 36 times the mass of Jupiter
but let us imagine that Zed our 42 a is
1,000 times as massive as Jupiter and
loosely 317,000 800 times as massive as
Earth gravity increases linearly with
maths so therefore gravity is three
hundred and seventeen thousand eight
hundred times are strong on Zed are
forty two a as it is here on earth with
that amount of force acting upon your
humble frame your skeleton would be
crushed into a pile of dust faster than
you could say quicksand it would be
equivalent to bludgeoning an egg with a
sledgehammer but let us throw the laws
of physics into a cautionary black hole
for just a moment and imagine that you
could walk uninhibited upon this faraway
rock in space in Einstein's theory of
relativity he proposed time is not a
constant it is neither a force but a
material into woven with physical space
space-time as it has come to be known is
akin to an elastic band which can be
stretched and contracted at will it can
also be bent time therefore is relative
to the mass and consequently the
gravitational pull of the closest and
most massive object to you there are
Arctic Terns that could migrate to the
other side of the planet before I could
finish explaining special relativity and
general relativity in suitable detail
that's if I could twelve thousand miles
they migrate twice per year if you were
interested but for now let us
Summa basic premise that if you were to
stand on this imaginary Zed r42 a that
time would progress slower for you than
your brethren back here on earth this
phenomenon is called time dilation as
gravitational force increases so does
the bending warping and hence dilation
of time itself when you have a weaker
gravitational field time flows faster a
stronger gravity causes time to trickle
slower but only from your perspective so
if you were to travel from Earth and
stand upon the surface of Z r42 a for a
single afternoon upon your return
everyone you knew and loved would be
long deceased your home planet would be
unrecognizable thousands of years would
have passed but to you the smallest
flicker of an afternoon would be all
that you had experienced and
unfathomably surreal afternoon with an
afternoon nevertheless this effect isn't
just perception Airy it is as real as
the butter upon my bread and yes it is
actually a form of time travel for in
those short few hours you wouldn't have
aged at all upon your return to an earth
many thousands of years older than you
left it that very morning your body
would have aged only a few hours in
reality time dilation isn't quite that
powerful in the vicinity of most planets
this preceding example is knockin on the
decidedly delicious doors of science
fiction but time dilation does exist if
you were to stand on the largest planet
in our solar system Jupiter none for
every second that passed by on your
watch then one second and 20 nanoseconds
would pass by back on earth that's not
even enough to affect the timing of a
boiled egg never mind the age dynamics
of your relations but it is
unquestionably present Jupiter is large
really large 1,300 earths could fit
inside of Jupiter
if it were holland which it most
definitely isn't i checked
although it is rather mushy but a mass
certainly doesn't have to be
unfathomably large for the effects of
time dilation to start messing up your
interplanetary schedule near the event
horizon of a black hole the point in
space-time where the gravitational pull
of the black hole becomes so powerful
that you can no longer escape its grasp
time dilation could very well cause your
minutes to turn into hours possibly even
years back on earth all this means that
if you were somehow able to define a
relentless pull of gravity and avoid the
minor inconvenience of massive
spaghettification you could travel
forward in time by spending just a few
hours at this exact point in space
within the grasp of a black hole but
never quite slipping forward if you were
able to make it back to earth that is in
one piece now we were getting technical
about it you wouldn't have actually
travelled through time at all but time
would have passed by at a different
speed back on earth relative to you
hence relativity nothing at all is safe
from time dilation not even the earth
itself or even your ankles let me
explain the pull of gravity gets
stronger the closer you get to the
incredibly dense core of our planet a
core which is approximately 2.5 years
younger than the surface but what about
your vulnerable ankles well they also
will feel a slow grind of time dilation
if you were to wear a watch on your
ankle and another one on your wrist then
over a number of years many thousands
the watch on your ankle would fall
behind your wristwatch simply because it
is closer to the immense source of
gravitational force that is the earth
beneath
if all these time phenomena I have so
far discussed have not yet left you
inebriated in a cerebral overdose of
factual soup upon your very own floor
then prepare yourself for yet another
heavy dose a factor or medicine every
effect I have talked about thus far is
caused by something called gravitational
time dilation you see time dilation is
more of a double axe it comes in two
flavors gravitational and velocity
induced we have already outlined how
huge masses can warp space-time itself
to slow down the flow of time but so can
one's velocity according once again to
Einstein's theory of general relativity
a person's perception of time is
relative to the velocity at which they
are traveling this effect which is hard
coded into our universe is most apparent
when two objects are traveling at
different velocities especially if those
objects happened to be timekeeping
devices in 1971 free physicists flew
around the world twice with synced
atomic clocks to test out the time
dilation theory upon meeting up once
again they found that all free of their
clocks disagreed with each other thus
proving the theory time dilation has to
occur as a fundamental unbreakable law
of the universe in order to keep the
speed of light as a constant the speed
of light is the great constant the
greatest equalizer whilst away sighs at
the latest Big Brother winner inevitably
and frequently varies as well documented
in a selection of trashy magazines named
after English greetings the speed of
light will never do as such there are
other constants such as Planck's
constant but none are as unshakeable as
see in physics C denotes the speed of
light in a vacuum 300,000 km/s the speed
of light is the great comparator in many
crucial equations if the speed of light
were to change by just 0.0001
it would throw off everything we thought
we knew and have as a species worked so
hard over the past millennia to uncover
about our current understanding of the
universe and everything it contains so
time dilation exists as a fundamental
property of our universe to ensure that
if one's velocity changes then time
itself must slow to maintain the
constant speed of light the speed of
light accommodates no one or no one
thing everything including space-time
itself must make extra special
accommodations for this Universal
equalizer to understand how time can
differ so substantially depending on a
person's location and velocity you must
take everything you imagine about how
time behaves and then turn it all on its
head naturally we think of time as a
river flowing downhill towards the heady
relentless pall of the future inevitably
and often unforgivingly so but Einstein
posed that time doesn't flow as we feel
it does the encroaching future that is
so omnipresent within our life
experience is no more than an illusion
an impressively sophisticated one
according to general relativity Einstein
famously said the distinction between
the past present and future is only a
stubbornly persistent illusion instead
think of time like a train with an
almost infinite number of carriages the
first courage is the moment and the
location of the Big Bang the birth of
the universe conversely the last
carriage is the last point in space and
time of our universe the point of its
inevitable death you can only see the
people and the events happening in your
carriage this is your slice of time your
present a moment in the space-time
continuum that you share with all the
other passengers in your train carriage
for passengers and different carriages
behind it in front of yours will have a
different perspective
of their presence their slice of time
there now will be entirely different to
yours their present could be your past
or it could be your future depending on
the location within the Train Einstein
theorized that through the mechanisms of
gravity and velocity induced time
dilation we can move to a different
carriage or partner train and thus our
anchor within space and time are now
shifts by one or more carriages
depending on the velocity with which we
are traveling and the gravitational
force of our current surroundings
however this example suggests a
potentially unnerving truth if time does
behave in this way it would also mean
that time is not something to be decided
and altered it is a static medium which
we simply move through this could mean
that everything that has happened and
everything that is yet to be has already
happened every tale has been foretold
every fortune has been realized the
future is not asked to make it is a
destination to reach we cannot change
what lays ahead in the train carriages
in front of ours we can only await the
point in time in space when we will
naturally reach that carriage each and
every day is a page in a book that has
already been written but before you fall
into an abyss of self-pity of you're
suddenly a mutable future do bear in
mind that this is not fact per se but
our current best working model for how
the universe behaves based on popular
theories importantly Einstein's
equations indicate that time has no
directional bias it prefers to flow
neither forwards nor backwards not even
sideways if it were inclined yet we
inextricably experience time going
forward there is a sensational
difference between what we experience is
the past and the future time has no
preferred
erection so naturally physicists have
been pondering this what seems like a
deep floor within our universe and it
transpires that what we believe is the
passing of time the steady rolling of
the wheels of the future isn't the
future at all there is no past and there
is no future because time has no
direction at least not within the realm
of existence that we call our universe
as Einstein said time is an illusion and
in the words of a great science-fiction
writer
long time EE sir the passing of time is
no more than a psychological illusion a
trick the world around us plays upon our
brain what in fact we are experiencing
is the terrifyingly stubborn process of
low entropy becoming high entropy
systems in thermodynamics entropy is the
measure of the order or disorder within
a system it eloquently describes the
nature of all things that will
eventually succumb to the decay and fall
into disrepair with all things in the
universe from a distant star to a ham
sandwich there are many more ways that
the particles within said thing can
become disordered and fall into a
chaotic abyss then there are ways that
it can remain ordered the star will
eventually die and implode into a dense
singularity and the ham sandwich will
less spectacularly but just as
inevitably grow molds and decompose
entropy explains why buildings will
always decay over time equally and
unfortunately so does the human body
therefore what we perceive as time
passing goes by is no more than a decay
and the unstoppable onslaught of chaos
in all around us people and animals
dying buildings our nature decaying all
these examples of entropy fools into
vesting wholly into a grand illusion
that we are
approaching some kind of future when in
actuality of popular science is to be
believed then the future is not a point
in time it is a point in the vast
continuum of space-time and it is not
ahead or in front of us it is in no
particular direction at all
we are not travelling forward no matter
how hard our brains toil endlessly to
make it thus thank you for watching if
you fully enjoyed this video then please
consider clicking the join button below
to join the private 42 community here on
YouTube where you'll get early access to
all my videos and private vlogs for
myself